back
right now you're being placed under
arrest for operating while on top skater
okay
yeah blue zero an Iowa teenager is suing
his hometown after he says he was
arrested for an OWI while he was
completely sober you know when he
accused me of being drunk that's when I
got really confident because I knew it
was going to go one way and it was going
to go my way 19 year old Taven galanakis
is a freshman at William Penn University
where he's a wide receiver for the
School's football team but on the
weekend of August 28th last year he was
about an hour north in his hometown of
Newton Iowa yeah so I was coming home
from one of my friend's house
um we were just watching some football
and I looked around like I think it was
11 30 if I can remember right
and I had a headlight out so my idea it
was raining it was cloudy and all that
really dark
so I used my brights galanakis says one
of his headlights was out so he put on
his brights within City Limits that's
when Newton Police Officer Nathan
Winters pulled him over
hi there how you doing sir good how are
you good my name is Officer Winters with
the Newton Police Department reason I
pull drum is because you have your
bright lights on you have a headlight
out so I just keep my brights on okay
well that's not legal oh is it no yeah I
just don't want a cart when car comes by
turn them off but like when you didn't
with me
oh you weren't close enough though
you're like yeah you're a while back it
has to be within 500 feet oh my bad I'm
sorry and you're not supposed to have
your brights on in the city limits my
fault my fault you got your license
registration insurance right yeah I got
you yeah it pulled me over
so then once he pulled me over he began
to be really hostile
and I could tell by the way like right
when he got to my window
just asking me if I had anything to
drink right away
you know
so it was just one of those things I was
like
it's gonna be like this so you know I
try to keep my calm keep my cool
where are you coming from
his house okay anything to drink over
there
I didn't hear what you said
is one of these
need one of these right here yeah I mean
that's a good start that's the
registration body camera video shows
gallonakis give officer Winters his
license registration and insurance
information after that he's asked to get
out of the vehicle all right that'll
work I'm gonna have you hop out with me
okay cool
power on or off uh you could probably
leave the car off do me a favor put your
gum on the on your dash there oh my God
yeah officer Winters then asks galanakis
whether he has any weapons or drugs on
him we're gonna go back here okay cool
you don't have anything on you no bombs
guns drugs no bombs with no drugs okay
let's go back here after that the
officer leads galanakis into the front
seat of his squad car how much have you
had to drink tonight none
what do you mean there I had nothing to
drink okay
why would you uh why would your eyes be
watery and bloodshot do you want to blow
me real quick you know I don't want to
blow you well I told him that I said hey
blow me and then he turned it into some
sexual right after that so
at that point I know who I'm talking to
you know he's not really professional
galanakis tells lawn crime Network he
wanted to take a breathalyzer exam right
away because he didn't have anything to
drink you know when he accused me of
being drunk that's when I got really
confident because I knew it was going to
go one way and it was going to go my way
so I constantly said hey let's let's
take the breathalyzer test and on the
body camera video galanakis can be heard
repeatedly asking to take a breathalyzer
test
and make sure follow me too man give me
a little blow I will no zero I will here
in a minute let's blow real quick stop
doing all these damn tests let's blow
let's get to business but first officer
Winters asks gallanakis to perform a
series of field sobriety tests can you
see my finger clearly yes sir okay
all right so I want you to put your left
foot on the line okay take your right
foot put it in front of your left foot
with the heel of your right foot
touching the Tory left foot just like
this okay but when gallonakis performs a
walking test officer Winters can be
heard saying he's not following
directions
[Applause]
so you want to get to nine
I guess so how do I turn
uh take a series of small steps one 13
steps
how many steps did I say to take
eight or nine I said nine why'd you take
14 and then 15. I thought you're gonna
tell me where to turn I said to count
your steps out loud and uh I try to
recall directions like hey can you tell
me again and you want to save them
clearly so I try my best and he said I
took one extra step when on the nine
step test he said to one extra step and
I guess that's how he determined if I
was drunk or high gallonakis admits he
may have slipped up on the tests because
he was nervous at the time maybe I don't
know maybe I swear my words you know a
little bit because I was nervous but
yeah this is basic nerves you know what
I'm saying all right during this keep
your arms down your side why are you
shaking so much it's freezing man
look at you you got all these clothes on
and I got it shorts on it's raining
and you false accusing me so of course
I'm gonna be a little nervous
yeah
yeah nothing to say after this
gallonakis is asked to perform multiple
other field sobriety tests is that six
inches here yep
how did I tell you to count
One Mississippi to Mississippi through
Mississippi
I also forgot how you talking about
I'm doing this pretty well so
um just follow my finger with your eyes
and your eyes only and don't move your
head okay gotcha
after telling galanakis he's likely
impaired you're showing some very strong
signs of impairment
officer Winters finally performs a
breathalyzer test
all right what I want you to do is make
a Tight Seal around this and blow
outwards like you're blowing up a
balloon okay oh all right you ready yep
okay you can relax
um so I'm gonna read your Miranda okay
when's it right now you have the right
to remain silent anything you say Canon
will be used against you in a court of
law while officer Winters does not tell
galanakis the results of the test the
zeros can be seen on the body camera
video after that he asked galanakis when
the last time he smoked weed was when's
the last time we smoked weed
do not remember that tonight who
okay well I would I think it's tonight
I've had no weed tonight
why do you think it's tonight why do you
think I'll blew the zero so now you're
trying to think I smoke weed that's
what's going on you can't do that man
you really can't do that absolutely I
can is he allowed to do that yes he is
Officer Winters again tells galanakis he
shows signs of being impaired I would
during my field sobriety I it is
indicative of impairment
so let's let's let's be honest I'm being
honest you throw some weed at your
friend's house no if you hit a pin nope
okay why is your why did you feel
sobriety so four
what why is your field sobriety so poor
and why are you so lethargic and slow
moving and speaking with a slurred
speech and your eyes are watery and your
eyes are bloodshot no other watery I
guess we're gonna rain right now
gallonakis tells the officer he doesn't
smoke because he's on the college
football team no weed I don't smoke weed
I play college football I told you that
we get tested every Friday okay don't
smoke me today's Saturday
okay there's three days for 30 days so
if I did a test next week I'd be off the
football team body camera video then
shows officer winter is speaking with
another officer saying galanakis
hesitated when answering about smoking I
said when's the last time you smoked
weed and he hesitated for a long period
of time and said I honestly can't
remember when officer went
to car he
turned away
right now you're being placed under
arrest for operating while I'm talking
okay
I'm not impossible
here yeah I blew zero so I ended up
getting put in cups because I blew zeros
and I get taken back to the department
and at that point you know it's it's
real life it's not a prank galanakis has
taken to the Newton Police Department
where he continues to maintain his
sobriety
on drugs a drug recognition expert later
determined galanakis was not intoxicated
at the time he was pulled over
gallanakis requested the body camera
video after his arrest and decided to
post it to social media gallanakis's
edited body camera video now has more
than one million views on YouTube when I
posted the video on to Facebook and all
of that the whole town was telling me
about their similar you know experiences
and all that and if if I'm seeing all
these comments about people saying
they're dealing with the same thing from
the same Police Department
we we got some we got a mess to clean up
and I feel like that's my job with the
exposure I got I got to clean up the
mess and I'm okay with doing that well
with the publicity my video again I
really hope you know it upbrings the
corruption in Newton in other towns that
have like similar issues
but yeah with the exposure of the video
I think it should just showing them hey
we need to do something better
you know because what they're doing is
not right galanakis tells lawn crime
Network he decided to pursue legal
action after an outpouring of support
online I really started getting inboxes
on Facebook Instagram and all that not
from Warriors but from people that
wanted me to uh talk to their lawyer so
it was just like maybe the lawyers
family members reached out to me saying
hey I don't really get a lawyer blah
blah gallanakis filed a lawsuit in U.S
District Court for the southern district
of Iowa against the city of Newton and
its Police Department the court
documents allege galanakis's civil
rights were violated and that the
department is guilty of false arrest
long crime Network reached out to the
Newton Police Department for an
interview but we're told they have no
comment at this time officer Nathan
Winters is still employed with the
Department reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie